[Musique]
avec la montée des eaux et les
changements climatiques de plus en plus
de plantes verront leur habitat
disparaître alors comment faire pour les
sauver
voici l'exemple du chardon de manga
[Musique]
dans le décor idyllique t il demain
gants une vaste opération de sauvetage
est en cours
[Musique]
une opération s'étalant sur cinq ans et
mobilisant trois centres de recherche à
la tête du projet lanci dénommé de parcs
canada
ce qu'elle veut sauver c'est un simple
chardon mais pas n'importe lequel le
chardon de mingue en une sorte d'emblème
pour la région les gens un grand
attachement aussi dans la région sur
cette espèce là on le voit bien le cas
il ya possible de voir un peu en fleurs
les gens courent ce vraiment
impressionnant le chardon de mingue ans
a impressionné le frère marie-victorin
lui-même quand il l'a découvert en 1924
la découverte la plus spectaculaire de
nos explorations dans l'antique aus team
à gagny est sans conteste celle du
chaton demain quand le chardon domingue
a aussi une valeur écologique il ne
pousse qu'ici dans tout l'est de
l'amérique du nord
ses plus proches parents sont sur la
côte ouest du continent à 3500 km demain
gants mais là bas ils se sont hybridés
avec une autre espèce de chardons
les individus de mingue en isolé sur
leur île sont donc tout à fait unique et
valent la peine d'être protégé il ya
tout le volet biodiversité
on sait jamais quand on enlève une
espèce d'un écosystème qu'est ce qui va
se passer par après
le chardon de mingue en soufre des
changements climatiques
ils poussent sur les grèves or l'eau
dans les baies ne gèle plus comme
autrefois en plein hiver la mer peut
venir endommagé les rives
avant 2016 par exemple toute une colonie
de chardons prospérait ici il ne reste
plus que deux petites plantes malingre
menacée à tout moment d'être emporté par
les vagues
ici une tempête en décembre 2007 une
grosse tempête qui a causé de l'érosion
on voit ici reste à un plan du chardon
qui est tout juste à la limite de la
zone des roseaux ont fait c'est 30 à 40
centimètres de sol qui ont été arrachés
par la mer à voir les colonies chardon
allait jusqu'à cet endroit là sur une
autre île de l'archipel
la mère a fait le contraire et l'a
recouvert les chardons de cailloux en
fait y avait jusqu'à 30 à 50 centimètres
des paies de ces cailloux locke était
par dessus l'épaule entièrement sur un
troisième site c'est la forêt qui
menacent l envahit la zone où poussent
normalement le chardon
l'autre chose c'est les hivers sans
neige le chardon de maga un bourgeon qui
est toujours son niveau du sol signé pas
protégée par une couche de neige
le bourgeon peu gêné et la plante mans
en 2017 quand nancy dénommé a mis sur
pied son programme de sauvetage
la population avait baissé de 70%
il ne restait plus que 444 chardon dans
tout l'archipel
elle a d'abord entrepris de dégager les
chardons recouvert de cailloux comme
chaque individu est numéroté et
identifié sur un plan on a pu les
retrouver
numéro 6 qui nous permet c'est quelque
chose qui peut pas être à long terme
parce que en tout cas joué contre la
nature mais comme on est dans une phase
d'urgence à court terme on essaie de
l'aider tard et jusqu'à temps qu'on
récupère la gêne et de celle de chacune
des colonies est là aussi fait couper
des arbres là où une nuisait au chardon
une autre opération temporaire la forêt
vont repousser mais ça pose quand même
assez lentement ici c'est pas mal plus
facile de couper des arbres rochers pour
10-15 mans est en quête de déterrer des
chars dont un à un
quand il ya des tempêtes mais il fallait
surtout favorisé la multiplication des
chardons
c'est là que sont entrés en scène les
centres de recherche comme le biodôme de
montréal andré nault et stéphane dumas
ont été chargés de produire le plus de
chardons possible à partir de graines
c'est très difficile vous savez
travailler avec donc aussi peu de grain
ça nous donne très peu de marche domaine
donc on est obligé de en sorte que ça
fonctionne c'est très délicat
[Musique]
on a fabriqué un terreau spécial
similaire à celui des îles mingant mais
on ne savait pas comment le chardon
allait réagir au climat de montréal sa
croissance a été beaucoup plus rapide
que ce qu'on attendait normalement les
rosettes deux premières années on parle
de schepper 30 cm on a terminé la saison
avec des roues zip de 84 cm alors
l'homme dans le pli de production n'a
aucun sens les rosaires superpose à
montréal le chardon fleuri dès la
deuxième année
beaucoup plus vite qu'en as-tu ça c'est
une très belle surprise on savait pas
qu'on va réussir est aussi rapidement
puis là c'est la situation donc idéal où
elles sont en fleurs ils sont vraiment
très beau très enceinte et on est très
content
même transplantés à mingant les plans
montréal et reste plus rapide que les
autres
on était vraiment surpris de cette
annonce attendait vraiment pas ça c'est
des plans qu'on a eu du biodôme de
l'année dernière sont arrivés déjà à 30
cm de diamètre qui aurait permis d'avoir
suffisamment d'énergie pour fleurir
l'année suivante et qu'on a eu plusieurs
cas comme ceux des 2 500 en flore se
tenir normalement à mes gants le chardon
reste sous forme de rose est en moyenne
neuf ans avant de fleurir et mourir
comme il ne se reproduit que par les
graines
il est très fragile aux tempêtes s'il
meurt avant de faire ses fleurs il
disparaît nancy dénommé a aussi demandé
à un centre de recherche ontarien de
multiplier certains plans par
reproduction in vitro à partir de
feuilles
ça lui permet de faire des tests on a
fait des carrés dans lesquels on a
enlevé une couche de pin puis dans
d'autres où on a laissé les épines au
sol puis ça ça nous permet de voir dans
quel compte 5 vents mieux pousser comme
ceux des classes et des plans qui
devraient tous réagir de la même façon
c'est l'habitat qui vont faire la
différence lors génétique est exactement
la même
simon piché mongeon lui a été chargée
d'étudier l'adn des plans c'est un
étudiant à la maîtrise de l'université
d'ottawa son travail aidera à choisir
les chardons qu'on utilisera pour la
reproduction
on va c'est finalement le déterminer
quels individus ont la plus grande
diversité génétique puis accès si on
veut la reproduction de ces individus en
particulier pour augmenter les chances
d'avoir une mutation qui serait
bénéfique à la population quelque chose
jour son étude permettra aussi de savoir
s'il ne serait pas préférable de croiser
les colonies pour l'instant par
précaution on ne plante à un endroit que
des individus issus de ce même habitat
les graines récoltées ici ne seront pas
semer ailleurs on sait pas depuis
combien de temps sont isolés chacune des
colonies du parc mais c'est pas simple
que ça fasse des milliers d'années
qu'est-ce que localement ses chars dont
la sont différents
puis se sont adaptés à différents c'est
ce qu'on renvoie les efforts de nancy
dénommé et ses partenaires ont porté
fruit jusqu'ici la population a presque
triplé entre 2017 et 2018 de 444 plan on
est passé à 1281 notre objectif c'est
que la population que se maintenir par
la suite de façon naturelle
on veut juste lui donner un petit coup
de main la montée à un nombre de places
suffisant pour survivre à long terme
mais on veut pas avoir à intervenir
toujours le navire quelque chose
d'artificiel
nancy dénommé songe à implanter de
nouvelles colonies dans les endroits qui
seront les moins touchées par les
intempéries
même là où on n'a jamais vu deux chars
dont la bataille n'est pas terminée
ça va bien c'est encourageant mais c'est
pas terminé
[Musique]